hey guys today it is January the 20th my
name is Jess and see if a bunch of these
parasites next free content update has
been announced and here's all the sweet
things you can expect from that the
update called infinity the armory
introduces two new maps for arena and
war zone respectively as well as new
weapon skins assassinations and Alma 343
hasn't revealed an official release date
but this one is expected to land next
week included in the pack is a halo 2
error battle rifle a suit of armor holds
Achilles and new card line Rex arrives
of oblivion and blood of Steve on Warner
Brothers has announced a mortal kombat x
el edition which will include Mortal
Kombat X and all of its crap loads of
DLC in one package MK XL edition is
coming to ps4 and xbox one but won't be
arriving on PC in addition to containing
all the characters from the first and
second combat packs it will also include
the apocalypse skin pack the Brazil skin
pack cold war skin pack cold raw
scorpion skin pack and lease tomorrow
skin pack basically if you're nuts on
what will combat and you haven't picked
up X yet this will have you sorted the
bundle launches on much one digitally
and installs a bit more division news
for you today as the file size for the
beta may have been revealed according to
reddit user legate 213 who claims to
have been invited to a private beta of
the game the beta client weighs in at
26.25 gigabytes on pc comparative later
divisions alpha client was 23 points 2
gig on xbox one we don't have the file
sizes for other platforms just yet but
presumably all will be revealed when the
beta begins on January 28 f x1 users and
January 29 for ps4 and
the only way to guarantee yourself beta
access is to pre-order the game although
if you'd rather try your hand at getting
lucky Ubisoft to do have a waiting list
which you can sign up for on their
official 2000mah site the beta features
early story missions on manhattan's
chelsea pier and will let people try out
pvp dark zone areas if you're more into
getting free stuff I can help you out
there too ubisoft is giving away
division dlc inspired by the games just
announced live action digital series
agent origins the series will follow the
stories of four division agents whose
gear sets and skills you can pick up for
your games I'm heading to the website we
have linked in our story on gamespot
when you get there redeem the code agent
origins and if you'll be good to go let
me know down in that comment section if
you have high hopes for the division and
if you'll be picking it up you can as a
game spot we've got stories on Star Wars
Episode 8 getting delayed and XCOM to
pre-order bonuses that is everything I
wanted to tell you about today but do be
sure the pot by same time tomorrow for a
bunch more news